l'action menée aujourd'hui visé atténuer
l'incidence turku des prix du pétrole
selon la banque du canada du moins les
problèmes dans notre économie sont
passablement plus grave que monsieur
harper et son gouvernement conservateur
n'ont jamais que près de m ce
gouvernement n'a pas de plan ils ont
tout misé sur le prix du pétrole n'est
pas tout l'économie car toute l'économie
canadien l'économie les bases
fondamentales de l'économie canadienne
reste très très forte
le prix du pétrole qui suit le taux
directeur de la banque du canada a
abaissé d'un quart de point regagné le
voir le budget fédéral qui reportait
décidément le paysage économique s'est
considérablement assombri au pays depuis
notre dernière table ronde avant les
fêtes ont ils ont sans doute beaucoup à
dire là dessus sur la lutte contre
l'intégrisme et la laïcité aussi car on
l'a vu le ton monte au québec alors
tâche à ce soir et à toronto
on s'attache à ben soir michel et daniel
sont avec moi bonsoir à vous deux très
content de vous retrouver tous les trois
commençons par l'économie pas ce qui
s'est passé tellement de choses depuis
notre dernière rencontre alors stephen
un peu a dit aujourd'hui
tasha que l'économie n'allait pas si mal
n'empêche avec tout ce qui se passe ça
va lui donner un peu des motets tenons
absolument je pense qu'il a beaucoup
d'aspirine dans sa boîte dans sa salle
de bain chez lui parce que ces jours ci
c'est très difficile aussi à prédire où
est-ce que ça va aller je pense le fait
que le gouvernement a reporté le budget
jusqu'en avril démontre que il l'espère
en tout cas que le prix du pétrole
commencent à remonter que la donne
change
mais c'est aussi possible que ça
s'empire alors ça démontre vraiment je
pense le point où le gouvernement essaie
de garder calme mais c'est très
incertain
alors daniel c'est toute la vision
économique de stephen harper qui est en
jeu
demain céline est une chaîne des tâches
à savoir faire neuf ans exactement que
six venant après le premier du canada et
à sept mois à ce moment là il ya neuf
ans il se disait le canada les
troisièmes plus importantes de
ressources pétrolières au monde
il y en a pour 40 ans et des milliards
de dollars au plus avec ce faire du
canada un pays très riche on va
construire des pipelines partout on vend
de pétrole partout le président des
états unis va être dans le coup elle se
taira c'est tout ça bien de s'arrêter en
tout cas je dirais pas s'effondrer mais
presque ça peut être reprendre et on
verra est ce que le fait que les
canadiens ont plus d'argent dans leurs
poches parce qu'il l'essence coûte moins
cher est ce que parce qu'on peut vendre
beaucoup plus de produits aux états unis
parce que notre dollar est rendu à 80
cents
ça va compenser si vous n'êtes plus
simple de penser que oui le gouverneur
de la banque du canada est un peu moins
essentielle
personne n'avait vu venir mais est ce
que stephen harper aurait pu agir
différemment c'est des choses qu'on
aurait pu faire différemment mais
personne ne veut venir mais monsieur
papa faire en sorte que le canada soit
prêt à absorber un choc comme celui là
il ya tout misé sur le pétrole en se
disant l'alberta la saskatchewan
internet vont être les vaches à lait du
reste du pays
et on le voyait vous savez pendant
plusieurs mois les les provinces du
centre se plaignait de la maladie
hollandaise on disait votre pétrole
faire en sorte que nos même facture
perdre du terrain
maintenant si c'est le contraire qui
éventuellement pourraient se produire
sauf qu'on sait pour combien de temps ça
va durer est ce que par exemple
reconvertir à une industrie
manufacturière la sauce fait pas en
trois ou quatre mois là ça me semble
évident que pour les prochains mois et
peut-être pour les deux ou trois
prochaines années
monsieur à peu va devoir
être imputables de la mauvaise situation
dans laquelle l'économie canadienne
risque de se trouver mon erreur attache
à bazoulé dire je suis un peu fatigué
d'entendre toujours que c'est monsieur
harper ou le pays qui a misé sur le
gouvernant qui a misé sur le pétrole
c'est l'économie qui a dirigé le fait
qu' il y avait une demande pour le
pétrole les prix étaient hauts c'était
une ressource valable qu'est ce que le
gouvernement aurait dû faire est
vraiment le plus bête non écoute le
gouvernement a baissé les impôts pour
tous les entreprises à ce que le
gouvernement aurait dû laisser faire
baisser leur maman être obligé de
dilapider davance les revenus qui dont
il aurait peut-être besoin aujourd'hui
pour stimuler l'économie
non ça c'est une autre histoire mais le
choix que monsieur harper a fait pour
dépenser le surplus n'a rien à faire
avec l'état de l'économie ontarienne
parle comme ça c'est complètement
différent mais les gens associent
toujours ces deux choses là ce n'est pas
la même chose du tout mais là est ce
qu'ils se retrouvent pas quand même dans
une drôle de position parce qu'ils
veulent toujours arriver à l'arrêt à l'
équilibre budgétaire mais avec la
situation actuelle est ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir y arriver mais ça c'est la
grande question écoute équilibre
budgétaire il a dit aujourd'hui c'est
l'économie continuait à rouler il
devrait arriver à cet équilibre
mais est ce que l'économie va va
s'améliorer probablement non alors il
voit soient coupées ou soit il a reculé
sur la promesse qu'il a fait pour les
familles en particulier pour le pour les
impositions des familles jouent
actuellement josé luis exactement et ça
c'est quelque chose sur lequel s'il
recule serait très coûteux quand ça
vient à l'élection alors ils pourraient
pas c'est très difficile pour lui qui ce
qu'il a fait ce choix là c'était une
erreur de faire des choix il n'ya pas
justice et pas seulement le gouvernement
qui doit s'ajuster damien tous les pays
et tous les partis d'opposition aussi
doivent s'ajuster et dans la mesure où
stephen harper se prépare à faire une
campagne électorale en disant moi je
suis le champion de l'économie
c'est une bonne nouvelle jusqu'à un
certain point pour les deux partis
d'opposition et du riz vous les avez
entendus cette semaine c'est une
rhétorique gratuite démagogique
ils n'ont rien dit autre que le dire que
s'il voudra plus non pas de vision
justin trudeau a été pathétique cette
semaine comme on l'a
notamment de care aussi ça ne va pas au
delà des condamnations
qu'est ce qu'ils ont à offrir comme en
eux et ils vont relancer l'économie
comment ils vont remplacer des revenus
du pétrole qui sont perçues comme france
soir parle de presque 5 milliards pour
le fédéral 10 milliards pour les
provinces qu'est ce qu'ils ont à
proposer
mais si j'étais chef l'opposition j'ai
exactement la même chose que parce
qu'ils ont maintenant ainsi venu un peu
vulnérable là où ils sont yes ans est le
champion
ils vont être obligés peut-être de faire
comme sur un peu c'est à dire de ne pas
tenir des engagements qu de revenir sur
des engagements que c'est là il reste
qu'ils vont être obligés de peut-être de
revenir par exemple sur le programme de
garderies de monsieur wiggers donc tout
le monde rires se met un peu m prix est
ce que ça joue sur l'échéance électorale
en tout cas on va oublier les élections
au printemps d'achat je pense que
probablement oui parce que il ya trop de
choses qui vient au printemps écoutent
ils vont pas déposer un budget en avril
pour ensuite c'est l'ancien élections se
sait ce que fait un mouvement
minoritaire mais je pense pas que ce
serait dans leur intérêt ici je pense
que monsieur un peu plus attendre
maintenant pouvoir que si d'ici à
octobre les choses ne changent pas ça va
changer pour le québec aussi ça change
la donne un petit peu ça change la donne
l'économie québécoise peut à terme
profiter de cette citerne entité sociale
mais à terme pour le moment je ne pense
pas que ça fasse très grosse différence
si ça perdure il ça peut poser un
problème sur le plan de la péréquation
par exemple mais sa part être pas avant
deux ou trois ans mais il ya d'autres
projets par exemple prenons le projet de
pipeline de transcanada
oui si les prix du pétrole continuent à
s'effondrer ou à demeurer à un niveau
tel que c'est pas rentable
ça pourrait remettre en question des
projets comme cela
ça peut jouer dans la mesure où à
l'alberta était une contributrice majeur
est ainsi allé plus d'argent contribuera
plus mais ça on ne sort pas tout de
suite
bon ça va pas très bien sur le plan de
l'économie pour stephen brun peut par
contre sur le plan de la sécurité parce
que pendant qu'on n'était pas là il ya
eu toute l'histoire de charlie hebdo
évidemment toutes les conséquences de ça
et il va vouloir jouer la sete cette
carte de la sécurité de avec un nouveau
projet de loi d'ailleurs qui doivent
déposer en début de session pour
renforcer justement les mesures de
sécurité d'achat oui et il faut se
méfier un peu de ce projet je pense que
la majorité des canadiens probablement
souhaite que ont fait un combat très
fort contre le terrorisme mais en même
temps c'est dangereux que si le projet
de loi va compromettre les libéraux
liberté personnelle et on voit déjà la
possibilité d'avoir de l'arrestation qui
est plus facile pour dans les cas où on
n'a pas la permission de la cour de le
faire on a aussi la situation où la
police va avoir plus de surveillance
internet et autres
alors c'est liberté là est ce qu'on est
prêt à les délaissés pour avoir une plus
grande sécurité je pense que le
gouvernement pense que oui mais ça va
susciter un très grand débat c'est une
question qui peut aider oui moi moi je
pense que cela va être sont ses
principaux chevaux de bataille pendant
cette campagne électorale il ya un
sondage au québec la semaine qui disait
que 16% de plus de québécois ont
maintenant une perception négative des
immigrants fait le même sondage le reste
du canada je suis certain que la revoir
à peu près le même résultat
quand vous regardez vous voyez jour
après jour des atrocités de boko haram
de l'état islamique etc
les décapitations les gens ont peur sont
insécurisés et que stephen harper impose
des mesures qui briment jusqu'à un
certain point les libertés individuelles
les canadiens m'ont applaudir j'en suis
certain et ils vont jouer son très fort
pendant la campagne électorale
à défaut pouvoir jouer l'économie aussi
forgé remous
chouette il ya cette carte-là la
sécurité à la carte aussi de ce qui se
passe en irak avec l'été avec le groupe
armé état islamique
le canada est impliqué dans cette
vieille ça aussi ce qui s'est passé
monsieur un peu finalement été pris en
flagrant délit de mensonge ou en tout
cas de d'inexactitudes à tout le moins
dans le sur le mandat de la mission
canadienne
ça fait un peu penser d'ailleurs aux
deux fillettes ou la main sur apple
savait plus trop comment expliquer ce
que les propos qu'il avait tenus puisque
pas tout à fait sa place est exactement
la même chose
écouter ces gens là se font tirer dessus
c'est qu'ils sont quelque part où il ya
des gens avec des fusées à face d'eux
ils nous avaient dit que ça se
produirait pas et ça se produit je pense
à soi désastreux pour monsieur personne
même si sur les mêmes niveaux écouter
quelques tirs sur toi quand tu es dans
une situation de guerre il pourrait
retourner à dieu mais ces gens là t'as
pas se poser est là c'est ça le problème
se met à partir du moment évidemment où
on tire dessus il faut répondre et
d'autre part je pense que le climat
général d'insécurité que génère charlie
hebdo l'état islam est tout sauf un en
sorte que les gens commencent à avoir de
plus en plus peur et ils vont être de
plus en plus tolérant pour ce genre de
choses là et pour les atteintes à la vie
privée qui pourraient résulter de
renforcement des pouvoirs des forces de
sécurité évidemment au québec tous à ce
climat ce qui se passe en fait ce qui
s'est passé en france qui se passe
ailleurs tout ça a relancé le débat sur
l'intégrisme rhji sur la laïcité on
regarde ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
on se demande ça peut se faire de façon
sereine
michel daniel ça m'étonnerait énormément
écoutez ce test a grossi lorsque
monsieur bédard dit du premier
schoolyard aujourd'hui le yoyo préciser
sa pensée dans un communiqué s'est pas
excusé remarqué mais écoutez dire que
monsieur couillard importe les valeurs
de l'arabie le sait c'est complètement
farfelu secoue yar est un être
multiculturaliste le multiculturalisme
est pas un concept qui vient d'arabie à
ce que je sache et dans la constitution
canadienne alors on peut l'accuser
d'être un multiculturalisme et mais pas
d'importer des trucs des habits mais ça
donne quand même une idée du temps que
le débat va prendre je pense pas
souvenez-vous de ce qui s'est passé l'an
dernier ça sera pas mieux cette année
heureusement on reprend exactement où on
avait le suisse ça risque d'être encore
pire dans la mesure où la le pq cherche
désespérément quelque chose pour nous
quand même promis il a promis à
légiférer et on sent qu'il n'a pas envie
de légiférer là-dessus au sens de l'art
merde royalement c'est pas genre de
débat qui ont envie de faire en ce
moment
s'offrir près de pau choix si le genre
de débat qui est important toutes les
sociétés devront faire et à ce qu un bon
moment pour le faire non ya pas de bon
moment pour faire un débat difficile
est ce que la laïcité c'est la meilleure
solution oui si on pouvait s'entendre
que l'état soit complètement laïque et
qu'on fasse sa religion à la synagogue à
la mosquée ou à l'église mais est-ce que
c'est atteignable comme objectif je le
sais pas ça sera sûrement pas facile d'y
arriver mais là où moi je donne raison à
fait des couilles assez que ont fait
pour ce genre de déballeurs pendant une
course à la direction d'un passé parce
qu'on sent jamais capable d'avoir le
moindre consensus tâche alors est ce que
c'est un bon temps pour faire ce débat
au québec
ben moi je pense est un faux débat parce
que vraiment ce n'est pas la laïcité
comme tel qui est le problème ou la
solution c'est le problème c'est le
radicalisme islamique on voit pas de
radicalisme catholique ou radicalisme
bouddhistes ou quoi que ce soit les
politiciens ont peur de le dire mais si
on veut combattre le radicalisme
islamique ce n'est pas en imposant la
laïcité à tout le monde à tous les
employés qui ne peuvent pas porter des
croix ou des kippas ou quoi que ce soit
il faut prendre les mesures sérieuses
contre le terrorisme il faut prendre
aussi qu'au port et à coopérer avec la
communauté musulmane pour qu'on ait
radicalise pas les jeunes ici et
ailleurs ces choses là sont importants
pas le gros faux débat sur créé
une charte de la laïcité mais mais
entendons-nous le signe religieux c'est
une chose et on peut avoir un débat
là-dessus mais légiférer pour encadrer
les accommodements je pense que c'est
quelque chose extrêmement utile et ça
peut contribuer à diminuer l'espèce de
phobie de quoi c'est ça mais il faut il
faut dire la vérité c'est que c'est
accommoder une certaine perspective
radical islamiste et ses 7 il ya
beaucoup d plein dynamisme la major la
face majorité qui ne sont pas radicales
comme cela et il faut dire que c'est ce
groupe le petit groupe qui est visé
c'est là qu'il avait pris on va pas
refaire le débat ici le mot lafayette
précédent le mot de la fin c'est que ce
bébé l'homme ont pour leur faire presque
à tous les panels dit merci beaucoup à
vous trois très heureuse de vous
retrouver le bail et dimanche à 11
heures aux coulisses du pouvoir
emmanuelle latraverse nous parlera de la
reprise des travaux à ottawa et des
défis du parti libéral avec le député
dominic leblanc